[Music]
the tabloids
yeah i have to ask you about this this
is a picture
and it was this article was all about
how jack nicholson and you go to the
lakers game together and the lakers are
getting beat so it's that you guys left
early before the end of the game yeah
and it was sort of saying like hey you
know you guys you guys walked out on the
lakers
well lakers were having a dry spell but
it's not like i have anything in that
decision you know what i mean what
happened nicholson says
all right so we're losing lakers are
losing by like uh 19 and jack says uh
something like this six minutes left
i go yeah yeah and he goes uh 19 points
they're gonna lose say oh you know they
could come back he's like well
i don't something like
they the lakers have to score
20
and okc has to score none
i go yeah yeah he goes we're going and i
go yeah i know maybe we should you know
we should stick around i think maybe
finish it off because we're leaving so
and so you know i'm trying to talk him
out and then all of a sudden you know
nicholson leaves and gets up and and so
i you know i'm not going to leave him
straight yeah let's go baby and
out we go and i i see even lakers are
like jack
but when jack nicholson says it's time
to go you gotta get it man you gotta get
out of there
we have a clip here from grownups too
yes uh tell us what we need to know for
this clip okay all right oh man what is
it god they told me four different clips
come on cut this part out would you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right it's uh okay
no no no okay i got it so it's an 80s
thank you it's an 80s we're having a
party late at night the grown-ups too is
really it's a fun movie it's a day in
the life of the guys i move back home
it's the end of the night we're having
like a a party at my house it's an 80s
party and i'm i'm kind of saying we got
older in the scene and uh the guys
aren't having it here we go let's take a
look at this clip from grown-ups too
yeah
how many of you guys have been to a
party in the past six months
a party without a bouncy house
a party where they actually invited you
yeah the party's over fellas we're
losers we're old
lamasoff totally surrendered he's got a
fanny pack on now for god's sake you
know what first of all it's a cervanny
pack a survival fanny pack with many
special features so you pull that
triangle and lasagna comes out
why don't you give it a shot
you got it i'll pull the string
[Applause]